so we have a spring here that has a
spring constant of 4 newtons per meter
what we then do is take a 10 gram mass
and we put it on top of the spring and
we push down to compress the spring by
10 centimeters
we then let go
and what i'm curious about is what is
going to be the magnitude of the
velocity of our ball here of our 10 gram
mass
right as the spring is no longer
compressed or stretched or essentially
when the ball is being launched pause
this video and see if you can figure
that out and i'll give you a hint the
energy in this first state the total
energy has got to be equal to the total
energy of the second state we can't
create or destroy energy
all right now let's work through this
together
so let's call this first scenario state
one
so in state one what is the total energy
going to be
well it's going to be the sum of the
gravitational potential energy so that's
mg times the height in state one
plus our elastic potential energy that's
one half times the spring constant times
how much we've compressed that spring in
state one squared plus our kinetic
energy so it's one half times our mass
times the magnitude of our velocity in
state 1 squared
and that has got to be equal to as we
just talked about the total energy in
state 2. well what's that going to be
well that's your gravitational potential
energy in state 2 plus your
elastic potential energy
in state 2 plus your kinetic energy in
state
2.
now let's think about which of these
variables we know and which ones we need
to solve for so first of all mass your
spring constant your gravit your the
strength of your gravitational field
well we know what these are going to be
these are going to be our mass
is equal to 10
grams the strength of the gravitational
field also the acceleration due to
gravity near the surface of the earth is
9.8
meters per second squared
our spring constant
is 4
newtons per meter
and i like to remind myself what a
newton is a newton is kilogram meter per
second squared so this is also equal to
4
kilogram
meter
per second squared and then we also have
a meter over there and actually these
meters will cancel out and that's useful
because it's reminding us that we want
everything to be in kilograms and meters
and with that in mind actually let me
rewrite
our mass right over here as 0.01
kilograms
and then let's think about what's going
on specifically in each of those states
so what is going to be our h1
our initial height
well i didn't give it to you but what
really matters is the difference between
h1 and h2 so we could just define h1
right over here to be equal to zero so
let me write that down h1 is equal to
zero and if we say that then what is h2
going to be
h2 would then be equal to 10 centimeters
but remember we want everything in
kilograms and meters so 10 centimeters
is the same thing as 0.1
meters what is our spring compression in
scenario 1 going to be
well that is going to be 10 centimeters
but once again we want to write that in
terms of meters so i'll write that as
0.1 meters and then what is our spring
compression
in scenario 2 going to be well we're
completely uncompressed and unstretched
so that is going to be zero meters and
then what is going to be our velocity or
at least the magnitude of our velocity
in state one well we're stationary so
it's zero
meters per second and what is going to
be the magnitude of our velocity in
state two
well that's exactly what we want to
solve for that is our launch velocity
so let's see if we can simplify this and
then solve for v2
so we know that h1 is equal to 0 so that
simplifies that right over there that
term is 0. we know that v1 is 0 so that
simplifies that term there
we know that delta x in scenario 2 is
equal to 0 so that simplifies
that term
right over there
and so we can now rewrite all of this
and i'll switch to one color just to
speed things up a little bit as one half
k times delta x1
squared is equal to
mg
h sub 2
plus
one half m
v sub 2 squared and now let's just try
to solve for this character so let's
subtract mgh sub 2 from both sides so
we're going to have one half k times
delta x sub 1 squared minus m
g h sub 2 is equal to one half
m v sub 2 squared now let's see if we
multiply both sides by 2 over m then
that will get rid of this one half m
over here so let me multiply that
i'm kind of doing two steps at the same
time one way to think about it is i'm
multiplying times the reciprocal of the
coefficient on the v squared so right
over here it's m over two so the
reciprocal is two over m
and we have to be sure that i'm going to
multiply times that whole side and so
what do we now have this is going to be
equal to
let's see it's going to be k
delta x
sub 1 squared over m
minus
2
g h sub 2 is going to be equal to v sub
2 squared and then to solve for our
launch velocity we just take the
principal root the square root of both
sides so i could say v sub 2 which is
equal to our launch velocity is equal to
the square root
of our spring constant times delta x sub
1 squared over our mass
minus
2 times the gravitational field
times
h2
and so we just have to plug in the
numbers now this is going to be equal to
and i'll switch colors just to ease the
monotony let me use a new color right
over here this is going to be equal to
the square root
of and i want to make sure all the units
work out so i'm actually going to write
this version of my spring constant so i
can work with all the units so it's
going to be
4
kilograms per second squared
and now delta x1 we know is 0.8
meters so if we square it it's going to
be times
0.01
meters squared
and then all of that is going to be over
our mass
which we know is
0.01 kilograms
0.01
kilograms
and then minus 2 times
9.8
meters per second squared
times height in the second scenario
which we already know is 0.1 meters so
times 0.1
meters and let me extend this radical
right over here and let's look at the
units first to just make sure we're
getting the right units so this kilogram
is going to cancel with this kilogram
and then we have over here we're going
to have something that's in terms of
meters squared per second squared and
then over here we're going to have
something in terms of meters squared per
second squared so that makes sense we're
going to have a difference of 2 meters
squared per second squared and then when
you take the principal root you're going
to get meters per second which is the
unit for the magnitude of velocity so
now we just have to get our calculator
out and calculate this so the point zero
ones will cancel out so this part right
over here is going to be four and then
from that i am going to subtract
two times nine point eight times
0.1
close the parentheses that's going to be
equal to that and then i need to take
the square root of all of that business
and i get this right over here so this
is approximately
1.43 meters per second
1.43 meters per second and we're done